well you look if you came to me and
offered to pay me eggs what I'm making
now and told me that I could stay home
I'm gonna certainly think about it hi
I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Michael Tanner
he's a senior fellow at the Cato
Institute and he's the author of work
versus welfare tradeoff 2013 Michael
thanks for talking to us pleasure to be
with you okay this is a fascinating
study that's generated a lot of feedback
in commentary and analysis essentially
what you're doing is updating a 1995
report where you looked at the benefits
of welfare programs versus the benefits
of low-wage work what do you find well
what we found out was that very little
has actually changed since 1995 that in
many ways welfare still pays better than
work at least in a great many state okay
yeah and you have you found that in 18
states welfare does pay less in in
adjusted inflation adjusted terms than
in 1995 but also that welfare pays more
than the minimum wage and something like
35 states welfare pays more than minimum
wage in 35 states it pays better than
$15 an hour and 13 states and in the
eight most generous states it actually
pays better than a $20 an hour job is
there a correlation where welfare pays
more that you see fewer people in the
workplace or higher unemployment rates
things like that we weren't able to
actually match unemployment rates or
welfare participation rates with the
level of wages well we were able to find
though is that those states that tended
to have very generous benefit packages
had relatively few people on welfare
participating in their welfare to work
programs okay yeah and this was part of
the backdrop of this is that in the
welfare reform that was done in the late
90s after 95 that was the linchpin right
that people had to work in order to get
welfare but you're finding that that's
that impetus has kind of faded over time
but many ways that was the biggest
surprise to me in doing this study
because I had been pretty much convinced
that as part of the reforms that Clinton
in the Republicans did in 96 they'll be
moving everybody from welfare to work
and that if you were going to get
benefits you were going to have to work
from now on right and we did see in the
90s and the late night here in the wake
of that mass
of decreases in welfare caseloads
caseloads went down and interestingly
poverty rates went down child poverty
went down black child poverty went down
but what we found now is that only
nationwide only about 42% of people in
welfare were actually participating in
work and work was pretty broadly defined
there that includes job search which is
looking for work or job training
programs going to college counts as work
and only about one in five was actually
in a non subsidized job so we really you
know aren't moving people from welfare
to work anymore somewhere in the study
you say you know that uh it's been noted
that the you know the highest marginal
tax rate paid by people is actually
people who leave welfare and go to work
and lose their benefits could you
explain what you mean by that I'm sure
what welfare benefits are not taxable
but wages are if you were earning a
dollar on welfare and you left welfare
and took a job and earned a dollar and
wages you would have to pay taxes on
that don't forget this the payroll tax
starts at the first dollar you earned
there's no exemptions no deductions
anything like that so that's a huge
marginal tax rate when you leave welfare
for work can you give us a kind of
estimate of you know or an average of
how much it does the welfare
compensation package what is the
equivalent in a wage well it really
varies a great deal from state to state
in the state like Mississippi which had
the lowest it was around sixteen
thousand a year and change which isn't
that great but in Hawaii you'd have to
have a job that learned as much as sixty
thousand dollars a year to break even so
it's a pretty broad spread right and and
essentially the argument that you're
making here is that if you have to make
a job if you have to make sixty thousand
dollars in order to get the equivalent
of what you might be able to pull in on
a welfare program you know it you know
Max Weber couldn't come up with
Protestant or Catholic people that are
going to do that right well then you
look if you came to me and offered to
pay me eggs what I'm making now and tell
me that I could stay home I'm going to
certainly think about it because work is
actually a sacrifice I mean when you go
to work there's financial sacrifices
involved childcare transportation the
clothes you have to buy to go to work
things like that and there's lots of
other things too there's loss of leisure
time if you're a mother with small
children you're not gonna get to be home
and see
children grow up the same way and work
is hard so you have to take that
sacrifice into account and balance that
against the possibility of income and
advancement and things like that it
begins to get tougher when you have the
thrill welfare in the mix what we're
what you're basically saying is that you
know work is hard and if you can get
something close to that without working
a lot of people are gonna take that sure
people on welfare there's no evidence
suggest there any lazier than the rest
of us but they're also not dumber than
the rest of us and if you offer them the
same incentives that's what they'll do
well we suggest a couple of things in
the short-term
number one is we really need to look at
those work requirements again and go
back to the idea that if you're going to
collect welfare benefits then you must
work the idea that you can have a state
like Massachusetts and only 18 percent
of welfare recipients are even in the
broad definition of work that's just a
disgrace we need to deal with that and
second we need to consolidate all these
different welfare programs in some way
and begin to put a cap on it
just recently Britain capped its welfare
payments at five hundred pounds a week
you know we're starting to fall behind
the Europeans when it comes to welfare
reform that suggests you've node we need
to rethink this speaking of foreign
countries one of the critiques I saw of
this study it was not actually about the
methodology or the conclusions but it
said look if we have these generous
welfare programs you know Cato is a an
open borders libertarian outfit you know
reason also big on open borders how do
you respond to the criticism that yeah
you've documented exactly why we cannot
allow immigrants into the country well a
couple things on that first of all the
Cato is actually advocated that we wall
off the welfare state rather than
walling off the country we've suggested
let's cut off benefits for welfare to
the new immigrants we still think
they're gonna flock to this country
because we're still the land of
opportunity the second part of that is
though is that welfare recipients or
I've sorry the immigrants actually use
welfare benefits at a lower weight the
native-born Americans they're not coming
here for welfare they're coming here to
work and second they actually add to the
prosperity and economic growth in a
country if you look to states that are
doing really well in terms of economic
growth they tend to be states that have
high immigration it's basically then
they come to this country they prove the
economic conditions for everybody
raising wages for everybody alright well
we'll leave it there I want to thank
Michael tanner senior fellow at the Cato
in
Institute and the author most recently
work versus welfare trade-off thanks for
talking to Reason TV my pleasure